it's been a really hard situation for
everyone and it's just highlighted that
we are facing a maternal Health crisis
for women of color Bowie died in May
from complications during childbirth an
autopsy reveals she may have had
seizures stemming from pre-eclampsia a
high blood pressure condition that
disproportionately affects black women
the CDC says that black women are three
times more likely to die from a
pregnancy-related complication it's 80
percent preventable what can the
healthcare world do and also what can
black women do themselves women of color
have to know that they're at risk they
have to know the signs to look for you
know their Vision being impaired
swollen feet headaches the awareness you
know implicit bias training you know in
the medical field
in the past black women have not been
heard they haven't their pain hasn't
been believed and that just has to stop